Are there women who marry men knowing
full well that they're going to divorce
them and take half their money that's
why they're marrying them yeah that's
why that's entirely why they marrying
them and how you know these are the
signs that she's marrying you for money
usually all right Sadia Sadia Khan you
you are a psychologist you specialize in
what Psychotherapy and a therapy for
relationships trauma and relationships
which we all yeah which we all can't
escape unfortunately yeah covers
everyone's life so I had this
conversation recently with someone it
see it seems promiscuity has has
advanced ever since the sexual
revolution first there was sex before
marriage and then people were having sex
purely for enjoyment and then having um
one night stands and now only
fans and you know the divorce rate is
rising which probably reflects that are
we building a better Society or are we
just disintegrating
I think if we ever are going to answer
that question the proof is in the stats
um in cultures where promiscuity is at
its highest we can't hide the fact that
divorce rates are then at the highest uh
mental health concerns are there at the
highest STDs are at the highest and the
measure of any success of any kind of
trend is the impact it has on children
whatever Trend a society is facing
whether it's um you know promiscuity
whether it's cohabitation whether it's
sex work if we just measure the impact
it has on the most vulnerable people in
that society that would indicate whether
it's good or bad for us and if we look
at the rise of priscu the number one
kind of sufferers of this tend to be the
children of such behaviors and therefore
I I would find it difficult to see how
sexual Freedom can really be healthy if
the people suffering are children
because they are then left with broken
homes not knowing who their father is
who their mother is they're left with a
a plethora of mental health concerns so
any any kind of trend that has a
negative impact on children cannot be a
positive impact on society yeah it seems
to be yeah is it is it worldwide you
think or is it just it is worldwide and
I would blame a lot of that due to the
globalization of social media I think
that you can be in the middle of
Afghanistan in the middle of Ukraine or
in the middle of um LA but your children
are what consuming the same content and
the sexualization of TV shows is really
interesting what I found really
interesting is over the years and I can
only account for my own kind of
experiences I would see people like
Britney Spears or Miley Cyrus they come
very cookie cuts are very clean so they
appeal to a very young audience and then
overnight they become hyper promiscuous
and hypersexualized so the young
audience is now kind of catapulted into
the sexual Revolution with the idols
that they were admiring they have no
choice but to catch up to their sexual
sexuality and as a result it's like
we're kind of propelling children into
sexualization which I just don't
understand the benefits of it's becoming
cool to the kids cool yeah it's hyper
cool for them yeah so so technology you
know it's made our lives easier in a lot
of ways but it seems romantic
relationships have become much more
difficult yeah than ever before you know
there's pornography for men which
eliminates the man's need to ever
develop courage which takes a lot of
courage to approach a beautiful woman
sex toys for women
you know millions of possible Partners
on social media and then one day
probably AI sex dolls for people it
seems like all of these things are just
destroying our our happiness cuz I don't
think anyone's happy watching porn all
the time M right I I don't know if these
women that
are entertaining hundreds and thousands
of men on social media are really
getting anything maybe just money but
we're all we're all lonely and and frust
frustated I think
absolutely are men struggling more or
are women struggling more I would say
men are struggling a lot more and um the
reason I say men are struggling more
with the Advent of technology is what
pornography does and what social media
has done it's placed Beauty on a
pedestal so what happens is men are now
seeking the most attractive woman to be
with that becomes a number one criteria
but I always say the number one
determinant of how healthy your
relationship will be is how attracted a
woman is to you as a man if you bypass
this very fundamental component you will
suffer in the forms of very abusive
relationships when you're a man who is
dating a woman who's super attracted to
you regardless of how you feel about her
she's attracted to you she treats you
with respect she'll be available she'll
be accessible she'll be very easy to
kind of get her to comply she'll be all
of those things that men are looking for
she'll be more agreeable
all of those things but what pornography
does is allow men to be hyper attached
and attracted and social media does this
as well to women who have no idea who
they even are and have zero attraction
to them so they go into the real world
in the pursuit of women and they bypass
whether she's attracted to them they
just want the most attractive woman in
the world and the treatment you get from
women who are not attracted to you is
completely different they treat you as
if you are a nuisance
they don't show you any desire they
don't show you any submission and most
of all they don't show you any respect
so what's happening now is that we are
cre cultivating households and
relationships where men are idolizing
women who have no respect for them in
return because they're placing
attractiveness on a pedestal and um this
can only lead to unhealthy outcomes
because women are the ones that file for
divorce and if you are selecting women
who are not deeply attracted to you and
not deeply invested in you you're just
delaying the divorce it's going to
happen but you're just delaying it and
making sure and she's just making sure
she can D you know take the most out of
you as she leaves so I think the
destruction of society is going to be
always in the hands of men and I think
they're suffering more from the Advent
of social media yeah it seems like
pornography has taken away the one thing
that makes a man a man which is having
courage yeah he never develops that the
need for it cuz he can just access any
woman he wants online and that's and the
courage never comes into the equation
and it's a recipe for rape um one of the
things that I think that is so bizarre
about pornography that nobody really
kind of addresses is here's the thing
the mindset of a rapist is I want to
have sex with a woman who doesn't want
to have sex with me it's that simple
that's the mindset of a rapist we have
taught everybody that rape involves
holding a woman down punch she's
punching crying kicking and only then is
it rap but the fundamental core
ingredient is wanting to have a sex with
a woman who doesn't want to have sex
with you what pornography does is allow
you to find a loophole to that desire
having sex essentially with women who
don't want to have sex with you who
don't know you don't see you don't do
anything don't want you so it gives you
that loophole and you don't even look at
whether mutual attraction or affection
is there now that is the fundamental
ingredient of rape and what porography
also does is exaggerate the um sexual
violence it uses sexual violence with a
woman that doesn't even know you're
there and you're watching it and
witnessing it there is no way that can't
be a recipe for sexual abuse in the real
world so I just think it just devoids
men of what their true instinct is it
which is to find a woman who desires
them is now replaced with just finding a
woman who will let him masturbate over
her I'd like to thank better help for
being a sponsor of today's video I think
a lot of my viewers are going through
things just like we all are whether
you're a viewer or not of this channel I
think everybody goes through something
and whether it's depression or anxiety
or you're just going through a tough
period of your life talking with a
professional can be really helpful you
know personally I go through just the
stress of talking to so many people that
are going through tough times tough
tough stories is hard on me and and
talking with a therapist is really
helpful so I I just started doing that
recently it's been really great for me
I'm I'm a huge fan of therapy and with
better help you can have your therapy
session as a phone call or a video
session or even messaging if you prefer
whatever is most comfortable for you I
did mine as as video which is great it's
it's just like being in their office but
you're doing it from the comfort of your
own
home and my better help therapist has
been wonderful right right from the
get-go he he kind of figured out what my
what my deal is and was really helpful
and what's great about better help is
you get paired with a therapist you're
matched within 48 hours in most cases if
you're just not feeling it with your
therapist you can try another one or you
can try as many times as you like until
you find someone that you're comfortable
with and you can do that in no
additional charge which is really nice
so if you'd like to join the over 4
million people that have taken charge of
their mental health by talking with an
experienced betterhelp therapist you can
actually get 10% off by going to
betterhelp.com
softwhite underbelly or click on the
link in the video description box below
thank you for watching and now back to
the
video yeah it seems like we've all
become very distorted yeah and I find it
so fascinating particularly when I watch
your channel we can all see what trauma
leads to prostitution or what trauma
leads to sex work it doesn't come out of
nowhere it's no one that sits there and
just comes out so when we can
disassociate and just watch somebody
getting that kind of treatment online
and not for a second think I wonder why
she chose that career I wonder how she
got here it is creating a psychopathy in
men where they're just not processing
feelings or not having that empathy same
in women that watch it I I find it super
bizarre women that can just sit and
watch pornography without even one once
reflecting I'm a woman I know that I
would feel quite violated if this was
happening to me and it was being filmed
how did this woman get here even women
can turn that off and just enjoy and I
just think I don't know if that's a
healthy world to create where we can
turn off empathy and replace it with
desire and pleasure well I think if the
woman experienced sexual abuse as a
child then maybe opens up her mind to
that yes I would hope so but what also
it can do is desensitize that it can
almost make it feel feel like this is
what my experience is somewhat normal if
I become hypersexual and I see people
being sexualized there's almost comfort
in the in the community so it can make
them really triggered but it also can
make them very
desensitized is female attractiveness
and and sexuality the ultimate commodity
in our society and sadly and women have
realized that very quickly what's
happened is that women are starting to
realize that in order to get a man to
invest in you to marry you to be to have
that kind of home gone are the days
where he's looking for somebody that
will just treat you well and be loyal to
you they are willing to sacrifice that
in order to be with a woman who looks
great and knows how to perform sexually
so what's happened is the measuring
stickma which men use to invest in a
woman is how much she pleases him
sexually so the good women or the women
that are not so sexually averse or not
so so attractive are just thinking I
don't stand a chance really because even
unattractive men can replace women with
um pornography but unattractive women
don't have a way of replacing men so
they they suffer and or they might turn
to is surgeries and fillers and all that
sort of stuff so being an unattractive
woman is a really difficult time to be
alive for them I think a lot of people
talk about how hard it is for men that
can't get women but no one mentions how
difficult it is for women who can't get
men they do exist there's a there's this
kind of rumor online that every woman
can have sex if she wants it it's not
that easy if you're an unattractive
woman men would rather turn to porn than
be with you so she has it way harder
than an unattractive man because if he
really wants to pleasure himself he can
do that himself yeah I've heard you say
one of the most interesting things I've
heard I think ever on this topic is
that uh particularly attractive women
are almost a different species than your
average woman they they go through life
with a completely different exper and
it's not all negative I'm not saying it
in a negative way a lot of it there's a
lot of perks to it but the main kind of
ramification of being beautiful is you
are you're a commodity or you're a
threat one or the other you polarize
people the people are never neutral to a
beautiful woman you can never just see a
beautiful woman and she just walks past
you and you're neutral you can do that
with average women neutral and then she
has to earn your either respect or
disrespect she has to do something to
cause that reaction in you as a
beautiful woman you can do absolutely
nothing and you can incite intense
hatred in either men and women mainly
women but even men they might see a
really beautiful woman intensely start
to criticize her so that they almost
kind of skip the rejection part they
kind consciously they're rejecting her
before she can reject them so they might
say things like oh she wears so much
makeup this is a or oh I bet that she's
had so much is their way of
unconsciously kind of diminishing her
before she has the chance to do that to
them or or they'll be hyper positive
about her so there might be men who
really put her on a pedestal there might
be women who want to be just like her
and either or is just not a fair place
to be in so the beautiful women either
over identify with being beautiful make
that their entire personality and go
down that career or they get really if
they're trying not to make that their
career not make that identity they
suffer in the form of vacuous
relationships and a lot of negativity
from uh same sex yeah that that's what I
see particular in the comments on my
Channel if I post a video of a
particularly
attractive female yeah or or even a man
who's attractive you know not necessar
physically but maybe his his personality
or his Charisma whatever the comments
will be crer than anything you'll ever
see that crazy like it the more oh
you're going to hit the wall and's see
what she looks like in 10 years you know
it's going to suck for her and you know
just all these terrible comments yeah
and which which which happens to
everybody yeah but I would I would
imagine and I can only go by my own
experience but I would imagine if I was
severely overweight or considerably
older or whatever and saying the exact
same thing I might still attract hate
because I know I what I talk about is
quite controversial but I doubt the hate
would be directed to my appearance
whereas the way I stand at the moment on
social media I'm not trying to be
negative there's lots of beautiful
comments and lots of very nice things
that are said to me but I went into
social media with zero kind of
expectation that any appearance Talk
would be it because that's not what I
came here for but it still becomes a
focus so um I kind kind of just I'm very
numb to it I something I've experienced
my whole life and I think I experienced
so much negativity with appearance only
because I never pursued a career that
monetizes appearance I was always a
teacher I was always something academic
I was always in that realm and in that
realm um people can't accept the Two
Worlds colliding so I always got a lot
of negativity from it which is fine it's
okay and and they're right one day you
do hit the wall and it will go and then
you won't have to worry about it so much
it's it's hard for um attractive women
also to to make friends yes very much so
so many of them that I've that I've met
don't if they do have friends they're
very they're not competitive yes that's
the key a very unattractive female would
be friends with a particularly
attractive one yeah it has to be um a
woman that genuinely is happy in her own
circumstance and there is zero
competitiveness but if there's even one
thing that she sees in your life that
she want and that could just be male
attention it could be the appreciation
you get from other people it could be
anything unfortunately the relationship
starts to deteriorate from the inside
out and it's very difficult because this
is the thing where guys always say oh
men and women can't be friends but from
my personal experience if if we if
you're an attractive woman if you don't
have any male friends you're going to
suffer in the form of very competitive
female friends so you're going to be
very lonely you're going to have to find
friends somewhere um so it is very have
you noticed that with women as well that
they tend to be very St but this is why
I just so I find the whole movement of
being a feminist and whole like girl
power and girls girl and I'm a girls
girl it's so fake it's so so fake like
the reality is you why would I why is
there girl code girl go when you guys
are the first to throw each other under
the bus if you're both after the same
guy or if you see someone who's more
attractive it's it's fake girls only
show girl code when or are only like
supporting other girls if they don't see
them is a threat the moment that girl is
a threat in any way shape or form then
girl code goes out the window there's
never girl supporting girls it goes the
gloves are off so that's why I've never
bought into this whole like feminism
nonsense yeah men don't really do that
no they don't do this boy you see a guy
at the gym who's who's really changed
his body looks really great you you'll
be like dude you look [__] awesome
yeah and you just congratulate him on on
what he's accomplished and if there is a
jealousy it turns into a healthy
competition or the jealousy is more
competitive it's like if they're playing
basketball it's like a form of
yeah it's inspiration yeah and but it's
an evolved trait it's definitely an
evolved trait because essentially we
have to rely on men for survival back we
couldn't Hunt and Gather ourselves and
the more women there would be in his
world the more unlikely we are to
survive and get food and resources for
our children so we' naturally see other
women as threats and the quickest way to
kind of reduce that threat is to either
undermine her beauty or undermine her
Chastity and suggest she's highly
promiscuous so those are usually the two
roots women go for when they're trying
to attack a woman a lot of Envy out
there yeah there's a lot unfortunately
MH are all romantic relationships
transactional I think here's the thing I
unconsciously they have I wouldn't say
they're transactional but I don't
believe in unconditional love I don't
think love should be unconditional
outside of your children and your
parents is not going to be unconditional
I think if somebody treats you badly
you're no longer attracted to each other
somebody provides no benefit to you and
you provide no you've got no connection
you're not going to be unconditionally
in love with them so I think there are
always conditions but some people's
conditions are far more transactional
than others yeah that's a good way
saying it yeah so I would say like for
example I might my conditions might be
that you have to be loyal to me you have
to be faithful and you know we have to
trust each other Etc but another
person's um condition might be that you
have to provide for me you have to
provide for my parents and you have to
do this and you have to do so just dep
everybody has conditions some of those
conditions are far more transactional
than others and how you know how
transactional it is is how attracted the
person is if they are genuinely
attracted to you it gets less and less
transactional as the attraction
decreases the transaction
increases who who benefits more in
marriage man or a woman I think there's
no benefit for a man unfortunately in
the Western Way of marriage I think it's
so sickening that you know we have this
agreement that women when they divorce a
man they can just leave with a lot of
his money or expect alimony for the rest
of their life and one of the things I
always ask women is are you going to
have sex with him after you divorce for
the rest of your life and she's like why
would I do that I like then why do you
expect payment for the rest of your life
that it's so strange that they want the
perks and the lifestyle of the one that
they attained from jumping on the back
of their husband after the divorce yet
they wouldn't give anything after the
divorce they didn't even give a lot of
that during the marriage let alone after
so I feel like it's a a really it's
almost a culture of creating sadistic
women by pushing that kind of you get
half after the divorce and they seem to
say well you know a lot of the excuses
oh but I wasted so many years being
dedicated to him I wasted but you both
wasted it that's a that's a risk you
take you he also wasted many years being
investing in you and he could have been
investing in lots of other people so I
just think that this that's why I would
be as a man living in the west unless
it's for religious reasons I wouldn't
recommend you getting married if you're
religious absolutely but if you're
non-religious and your wife is put or
your girlfriend is putting pressure on
you ask her why ask her why CU a lot of
them see it as a life insurance for
after they get divorced they still have
a payment
plan but this is the extremities this is
not the average woman I would say this
is more the extremities but
unfortunately that is becoming the
culture so I'm sure in your practice you
see a lot of women that
are you know getting into things that
that look like a sugar baby type yes
absolutely
relationship um
Are there women who marry men knowing
full well that they're going to divorce
them and take half their money that's
why they're marrying them yeah that's
why that's entirely why they're marrying
them and how you know these are the
signs that she's marrying you for money
usually she's from um she's not got her
own money she's got nothing to lose from
the marriage so she will have no no
money of her own or no career of her own
or she would have been married to a
really rich man before and set up a
business from that but there's been a
pattern of even know like no money or
relying on men for money another thing
is she usually comes from a broken home
yet she pushes the idea of marriage it's
really strange that what I notice a lot
with these sugar babies they usually
come from a broken home this is no
insult it's just you know what I what I
or gold diggers or gold diggers yeah
they usually come from a very broken
home without a father figure and this is
why fathers are so important because the
path that leads women down is not a
healthy one but they come from that
background yet they'll say to their
boyfriend who they've only been with for
6 months I'm a traditional woman I want
to get married I want to have kids and I
want to get married so they pushed this
idea of marriage when they never saw it
growing up they've had sex with plenty
of men before marriage they have no idea
about how to be a wife or cooking or
cleaning or any of those things because
they didn't witness that in their home
they didn't see Mom and Dad you know
have dinner together every day and mom
being loyal to a man or anything they
didn't see that yet they pushed the idea
that they want to be married and they
want to have kids they make marriage the
focus before prematurely they really
really push marriage prematurely so you
haven't even known them well enough but
they they really push the idea of
marriage and they they you can't even
mention the word prenup it's a forbidden
word if you're in a relationship with a
woman and where the word prenup is
spoken like it's you're scared of what
she's going to say she's planning to
divorce you that's it whereas a woman
who has no plans to divorce you treats a
penup just the way you treat car
insurance you have no plan of getting
into a car crash but you take out
insurance because it's a logical thing
to do and you hopefully she would have
equal amount to lose but when when a
woman has every intention to divorce you
the penup is not allowed to be mentioned
and she'll say it like you're being so
unromantic because you mentioned it but
the reality is the person who doesn't
want the penup is the person that's
planning the divorce person that
mentions a penup is just being cautious
just like you would with health
insurance the person who avoids it is
the one that's planning it so they have
these kind of signs and symbols but more
so than anything they don't have
Traditional Values outside of the idea
of getting married none of their
lifestyle is traditional nothing's ever
been traditional in any way shape or
form but when it comes to marriage for
some reason they're pushing for it um so
it's it's obvious to a woman but for men
who are particularly when they are hyper
attracted to a woman they um lose focus
and they can't see straight and they
they have no other options in their
minds they have no options and and the
other thing they just don't know what
real love even has tasted like I think
if you're going to get involved with a
woman like that you have to have like
seven options you have to and if one
women like that don't go for men like
that I'm babies and gold diggers they
don't go for men with options oh they
want guys that are they want guys that
are you know have limited options yeah
they don't go for men with options
you'll see very few sugar babies that go
for men who are at their Peak and there
very few will go for men that have high
self-esteem very few will go for men
that grew up in a really healthy
relationship with their mother they
usually they they can sniff out men with
very low selfesteem and limited options
and how you can tell a man's got limited
options is your beauty is enough to get
him invested there's nothing else to it
you don't even have to talk about a lot
you don't have to invest a lot and you
know I I'm in Dubai where I see this
quite regularly and you'll see they'll
go out for dinner and she's not even
talking to him she's on her phone but he
worships her and she knows that it's
purely physical and because she knows
she can manipulate a man physically she
automatically knows this man is probably
used to pornography and I'm the best
he's ever had and therefore he's not
going
anywhere it seems like
marriage is is not even an option for a
lot of people now it that but one thing
I'm curious about I'm Muslim so I very
much advocate for marriage but I'm it's
by the eyes of God but if I wasn't
religious I wouldn't understand why
people want to get married if you
cohabit and have kids anyway yeah
everyone's doing that yeah so I but I am
curious what what is the reason that
women give or men give for getting
married if they don't have a religious a
lot of it is just the pressure in
society to that's what we all did that's
what our parents did that's what okay
it's just the next step to do it's like
it's what you're supposed to do and and
when you're when you're madly in love
with somebody it just seems like the
natural Next Step okay but what if
you've already had the
children I haven't been in that
situation yeah but I'm just but now that
I'm divorced it's going to be very
interesting to see what my next step
would be yeah I'm just curious what is
if you've already had the children you
already lived together why is marriage
the next logical step after after your
your video and James seon's video I'm
not sure this is not to put people off
marriage it's to put people off marrying
the wrong person there's a very big
difference I'm a big advocate for
marriage huge advocate I'm a Muslim
woman I'm very much promoting marriage
is good for children and so is James
yeah yeah so it's literally for children
it's essential but the poor selection
process is the only thing you can blame
for when you're taken to the cleanest
afterwards that's it there's no other
cause it's not the woman it's not this
it's poor selection and unfortunately
because of the sexualization of what's
going on in social media um selection is
getting worse and worse for men so many
people are getting by without any type
of romantic relationship in their lives
but they do
suffer yeah they romantic relationships
that important in our lives they're the
fundamental ingredient for anyone's
mental health you cannot get through
life without social connections you
physically can't do it we are designed
to be attached to when you take a new
newborn baby as soon as they're born if
it doesn't have someone to attach to
they essentially would erode they've got
no one to protect them now I've met so
many men who have not been in
relationships for many years because
they've got pornography and they're fine
but your body craves the touch and
oxytocin of a human being it just craves
interaction it craves being seen and
heard you crave these things because
that's how you get feed back into
knowing that you are sane and how I can
tell somebody is super super lonely is
they they they they have very imaginary
relationships they'll be intensely
invested into somebody they've met on
social media that there's no reciprocity
or they will ruminate thoughts about a
conversation that they had two three
months ago and it doesn't come out of
their brain so what happens when you
don't have human interaction enough the
one or two human interactions you do
have uh can be can leave your brain
reeling over and over and over again
because your brain is trying to look for
the sources of connection so if you
don't give it to your brain it will
create imaginary ones and it's almost a
form of
psychosis
sadly what what should we be asking
ourselves before we enter into a
romantic
relationship um how am I using this
person and what am I using them for most
of us go into relationships with
something we're using them for then we
can either be using them as a numbing
cream to get over an ex partner we could
be using them as a way to feel stable
because of um you know we've got no
finances ourselves we could be using
them as an ego boost because I've gotten
a bit older as a man I want a young 27y
old so I can walk into a room and people
can stare at me how am I using this
person we're all using this person to
some extent now if the answer is healthy
it's because I'm using them because they
make me feel safe I can help make them
feel safe and we can provide something
for each other that will create a good
connection I'm using them because they
make me me feel safe and I hopefully
make them feel safe that's my usage
that's a good usage yeah if we're using
people because they make us feel
emotionally safe they make us feel heard
they make us feel seen and they make us
feel loved if that's your form of using
them that's okay that's a healthy form
of using but if I'm using them because
there's an unmet need here or there's an
ex that hurt me in that way or my father
didn't do this and you need to now do
that my mother caused this traum now you
need to do this if we're using them from
that perspective you're it's not going
to last the glue is too weak I've heard
you also say that in marriages we we've
replaced Duty with Hedonism yeah sadly I
mean the thing is like family members um
before you know when we were more
collectivist we would have a duty to of
care to others we've replaced that with
a duty of care to ourselves we've
replaced everything to self-love
self-care self self we've just replaced
everything every almost everything has
self in front of it um we have I can't
think of the last time we've got a
concept or a trend that involves um Duty
and it's obligation and responsibility
these things are now seen as boring and
they're seen as oppressive so what
culture has done is turned Duty into a
form of Oppression and Hedonism and self
selfishness as a form of Liberation and
it's indoctrinated all of us and it
seems like for a lot of people once the
novelty of the romance wears
off the routine of of everything just
becomes too boring to tolerate when you
can no longer feed my ego I have no duty
of care to you is what we're getting if
you can no longer pay all my bills I
have no duty of care to you or if you
can no longer make me feel or look good
in front of my friends and if you no
longer can arouse me sexually the way
you're used to I have no duty of care to
you anymore so the lack of Duty of care
to the people that you've created
children with you've created homes I'm
not saying everybody's perfect Sometimes
some Partners really do push you but I'm
just saying saying in general the lack
of Duty of care is something that I
think it actually starts from the home
uh I grew up in London and one thing I
just found
so bizarre is children would move out
from the age of 18 and 17 18 they'd be
looking to move out or their parents
would try charge them rent and 18 is so
young to me and you don't really earn
enough to do that but there was no duty
of care after that age and then what
that does it comes full circle what
would happen is the children would no
longer care about the parents as a p
parents would Age so the duty of care
would stop so young um I can only
compare it to my own culture I'm not
saying my culture is perfect by any
means but the duty of care never stops
and it then reverses from the children
then caring to the adults until they
pass but the duty of care just doesn't
stop and I think that's what
collectivist cultures have kind of tried
to maintain but it's again it's
dissolving due to Western kind of
ideology and
individualism yes you know like
sacrifice is such an important part of
everything we engage in yeah you know to
become a successful in your to become
successful in your career you need to
sacrifice a lot of time and get an
education or spend a lot of time and
effort into that or to develop AAL
healthy body you need to put a lot of
work into at the gym but romantic
relationships we don't seem to
understand that and sacrifice is not
really even on the in the discussion
it's people will go into a marriage
without bearing in mind what the
sacrific that it involves at all and the
main sacrifice it involves for men and
women is Alternatives and unfortunately
we live in a time where both men and
women are saturated with Alternatives I
would say women more so than men because
of the Advent of social media and dating
apps means that they can just jump
online and on that day they get
Alternatives but the inability to
sacrifice Alternatives and that includes
pornography it's not just human beings
and the in and it also includes like you
know doing any behaviors that would
compromise the relationship but the
inability to make sacrifices is really
the core reason why relationships are
falling
apart a common question asked by men is
what do women want but I think the
answer that answer never leads to the
man getting the woman that he wants yeah
I think the more important question
is what kind of man are women attracted
to yeah okay that's a great question
that's a way better question rather than
what do we want because if you ask a
woman what she wants she oh I want a man
who's nice to me and he's he's nice to
my parents kids whatever he's got a good
sense of humor but what what women truly
want
is I would say and this is I I think
this is universal and they disagree with
me but I really do and I I've said this
a couple of times the core thing for
women evolutionary wise is somebody they
cannot manipulate you could be David
Beckham I could be dating David Beckham
right who is David Beckham but if I
realize in very few conversations that
he's a bit of an idiot I can tell him
I'm here and he believes me or I can
tell him I need I lost my wallet and he
gives me money or he I can tell him I'm
with my friends and really I've got
another man here and he believes me
David Beckham becomes somebody I don't
respect David Beckham becom somebody I
leave on red and won't even reply to his
messages so what happens is the in the
ability to manipulate a man is something
that women are not all women are
intending to do this we're not intending
to do this a lot of women majority women
are not intending to do this but when
they meet a man they can do that to you
good women filter themselves away from
him if a good woman would see that even
David re I don't want anything to do
with it a bit he's lost his appeal it
will make only bad women select you
women that are planning to come home
late women who are planning to talk to
their ex-husband or like booy women who
are planning to still you know sell
their body online or whatever it is so
when you are a man a woman can
manipulate automatically she cannot be
attracted to you she can't be attracted
to
you uh it kills attraction and here's
why it kills attraction so deeply it
kills attraction is because un
fundamentally we're still looking for
someone to protect us that's how women
are designed now if you can't spot how I
might be a threat to you and the threats
that I'm creating in your life by maybe
I'm talking to another man or I'm still
selling my body or I'm still doing this
if you can't spot those threats how can
I trust that you would be able to spot
the threats and me and you go out and go
into new environments or how can I trust
that when another woman tries to
manipulate you you're going to stand
your ground and see through it I won't
be able to relax because you can't
protect me how would you how how can I
if you if I can manipulate you anyone
can so the thing is when people always
think oh woman cheated woman cheated but
to get there yeah do sorry sorry but to
even get to the cheating part it would
have been slow and steady manipulation
slow and steady lies that you believe
excuses that you accept timings that you
don't add up you're not connecting the
dots so by the time she gets to cheating
it's not the cheating that led her to
leave you it was the ability to lie to
you and you believing it throughout the
years that led to the cheating and then
she met somebody she can't lie to or
doesn't fall for her nonsense and she
automatically seen as a man so the
cheating and all these things are not
the issue it's how much did you get Now
by all means I'm not saying you need to
be a toxic man and say where are you
going what are you doing this that and
the other no no no that's not what you
need to do that's the opposite of what
we want we don't want that we don't want
insecure but how you become a man that
you cannot manipulate is firstly you're
a man that doesn't idolize
sex she can't treat you how she wants
and then just simply because she sleeps
with you that night you forget all about
it that's the first thing you don't
idolize se but the second thing is
you're looking for alignment between her
words and her behaviors if you are a man
and you can align and you can see that a
woman's behaviors and her words are
totally aligned she knows she can't
manipulate you but if if you're a man
that just believes what she tells you
and ignores all of her behaviors ignores
all of her past ignores all of her
traumas just because you hear what you
want to hear unfortunately she puts you
into the category of the men she can
manipulate and therefore you'll only
attract women who are planning to
manipulate this is why nice guys finish
last this is why nice guys finished last
and one thing I have to say about nice
guys that finish last in all of my
experience of working with these guys
they're not it's not that they're nice I
would I would replace that it's not nice
guys finished last it's naive guys fin
finish last you can be incredibly nice
but if you're not naive there'll be
nothing to worry about it's naive men
that finish last and here's I think the
fundamental ingredient of naive men they
don't they they either grew up being
hyper attached to their mother or having
no father and I think this is a really
important trait that I find in naive Men
what happened is that they either had no
father so they just didn't get his side
of the story or when they had a toxic
Father which made them over sympathetic
to their mother so then what happened is
they just grew up thinking mom is right
Dad is bad they grew up with that
dichotomy and as a result they somehow
go into the real world thinking women
are innocent and men are bad so if she
says to you my ex was so toxic he was a
narcissist he's like oh my God I totally
believe you poor thing let me help you
but whereas if you speak to a man who
had an even skew growing up he would
know that Mom Mom can be a nightmare
sometimes Poor Dad look how she bullies
him and dad can be so annoying oh God
they're both a bit of a nightmare when
you grow up with that even playing field
when a woman says to you oh my ex was an
narcissist my ex was so abusive my this
happened to me what was me you're
thinking hang what did you do because
you experienced that at home CU I I say
this is somebody who's very attached to
my mom and dad but when my mom would say
to me oh you know your dad did this
today I'd be like yeah but Mom what did
you do I know come on be honest what did
you do because they're both as bad as
each other but when somebody hyper
attaches to one pair parent they take
that kind of blinkers into the real
world so I would say nice guys what
happened is either they just took one
mom side too much or they just didn't
question reality they have a really poor
relationship with the truth they don't
look for truth they just look for what
they want to hear so whatever's easier
for them they'll take that they don't
fact checked anything so I would say
naive guys finish last and if you want
to be naive and you want to believe that
this girl who you know is you know maybe
a quarter of your age and genuinely
loves you and is only talking to her ex
because he's so toxic and she just needs
closure feel that guy that believes it
just believe you're going to be upset
coming
forward yep that's good
advice certain men have given all men
the reputation as being liars and
cheaters Yes but in reality I think I've
heard you say that women are
typically more guilty of than than men I
would say women are B by far more guilty
of this and I can't believe that we've
kind of created this culture where we
just believe that men are you know the
liars and the cheaters and I find it so
fascinating that I'll have clients where
the woman is literally cheating on her
husband and she'll say men are trash
those words would leave her mouth when
she's the one that's causing the lying
and she's like oh because here's the
thing I think here's the key difference
between men and women women genuinely
believe their lies they believe the lies
they tell themselves so when they say
but it's not an affair it's just
emotional and I'll say oh you had an
emotional affair yeah it was just an
emotional affair did you ever sleep with
him only a couple of times but it was an
emotional affair they use that word
emotional affair if I could give one
piece of advice to men if you've ever
heard the word emotional affair she's
been having plenty and plenty of plenty
of sex plenty and then some they use the
word emotional affair to make themselves
feel less guilty there's no such thing
as an emotional affair look I have many
many many M male friends in in my life
who I'm very very close to now if we're
going to use the term emotional affair
that could be seen as an emotional
affair because I talk to them every day
I love them I care about them they care
about me we call each other whatever it
is the re key reason it's not an affair
is because there's no sexual interest on
both if you're saying emotional affair
what makes it an
affair it would just be a friendship no
the fact that they're saying emotional
affair is their way of diluting the
truth there was physical relationships
and here's a bigger problem men believe
it
the bigger problem is oh no she had an
emotional affair I think she started
talking to the guy but nothing happened
you're a man right you're a man ask
yourself this if you're a man talking to
a woman that you know is interested in
you so much so that she's risking her
relationship are you just going to talk
to her are you not going to with her so
you're just going you're just believeing
your woman's version of events but try
and think of it from the perspective of
the man that she's talking to there is a
woman who's married or has a
relationship and she's risking it all
and sending you pictures or sending you
messages and calling you late at night
wouldn't you think who she's risking it
all let me try my luck how does it stay
an emotional affair in your mind now
maybe there's times that there are
emotional Affairs because you know they
live in a different country or this and
that happens but there some seems to be
a get out of jail card with the word
emotional affair because men seem to
think if it's just an emotional affair
it's okay but it's usually they're
telling themselves this lie it's not
true emotional affair means physical
Affair but you're if look if my husband
comes to me and says sa I'm having an
emotional affair I'll go shut the [__]
up you're sleeping with this girl and
I'm going to DNA test everything before
because I'm smart enough to know there's
no such thing as an emotional affair if
I tell a man that for some reason he
wants to believe that it was just an
emotional affair because it protects his
ego I would honestly say wake
up interesting what what what do men
misunderstand about how women operate
they genuinely well some like I said
naive they they're naive but here's what
the main thing is they think women don't
care about attraction this is the
fundamental mistake men make they think
women don't need to be attracted and
don't we do I'm not saying you need to
be super handsome but we have to be
attracted to you whatever that is some
women are attracted to dadbods some
women are attracted to short men from
women are attracted to any race any
color any size but they have to have
attraction for her to respect you and
have a fear of losing you without this
attraction she has no fear of losing you
zero attraction is fundamental for women
and what happens in this day and age or
this kind of culture is back in the day
I'm not saying it was as essential I I
would imagine in my parents generation
particularly in Pakistan where I'm from
attraction is not relevant it is not
relevant you can be happily married and
so on and so forth in this day and age
where there are so many channels to meet
men that you are attracted to and make
you feel more attractive when when you
have a man that you're attracted to
giving you attention as a woman you feel
more desirable compared to a man that
you're not attracted to like for example
I might be waiting at the bus stop and
some and me I can if if it's a a really
handsome man comes up to me and ask me
for my number I say I'm really sorry I'm
taken but thank you so much have a great
day now if a crackhead comes and says
that I'll say shut the [__] get away
from me
attraction is the fundamental difference
is how I'm treating them so when men I
think what they get wrong is they think
they can buy attraction they think if I
treat her well if I give her this
lifestyle if I show her safety if I can
do this if I can do this I can do this
she will love me deeply unfortunately
attraction is similar to Friendship you
can't buy it you cannot buy it and you
can't bypass it so I think the
fundamental mistake men make is I think
attraction is something you can
compensate and I know I've said before
in interviews that you can make up for
looks by being funny and Charming I
agree but the key I'm still sticking to
that what I'm saying is she has to be
attracted to you it could be your sense
of humor she has to find you physically
attractive if she doesn't find you
attractive there's nothing you can do if
you if she just doesn't do I I need to
explain that a bit better because I've
said in previous podcast that you can
compensate it through money or through
um charm what I mean by that is she
still has an underlying attraction you
can find a really funny man attractive
you can find a really Charming Man
attractive you might not be physically
but you can find him that but if she
hasn't if you haven't sparked that
attraction in her you you won't get the
respect out of
her there's so much we don't understand
about relationships isn't there and it's
so hard for men as well I had a client
the other day and I was trying to
explain to him he made this mistake
where he grew up watching a lot of ROM
comps so he would do this thing where he
would write letters to girls and poems
to girls and he would treat them very
well and I just said unfortunate Ely we
are not attracted to that because we
even though it seems really nice and
caring or whatever it is it's still a
feminine method of expressing love and
we're looking for the masculine method
we would rather be with the guy that we
say my anniversary is coming up on our
anniversary is cominging up Wednesday
don't forget than the guy that writes us
poems before he goes to bed because one
leads into masculinity the other leads
into femininity so the things that we
complain about oh he didn't remember you
know it's coming up next week or he's
never written me a birthday card the
things that we complain about is
actually the things that make men men so
it's very hard to decipher
us who who has it more difficult in
society today men or women just in terms
of everything not just you know what I
would say and I know this is a a cop out
but I say the the people that haveit the
hardest are unattractive people I would
say it's unattractive people have it
absolutely the hardest and the reason
why they have it so hard now compared to
before is before people would stay with
people on this similar level they would
just want to be with somebody on the
same level if you look at our most
people's parents they're relatively
matched on attractiveness yeah my
granddad and my grandma they make
perfect sense my parents make perfect
sense their parents made perfect sense
whatever it is what's happened now is
people don't want to accept their own
level you could be a really small man
who's really overweight but you still
want to watch Latinos having sex on porn
or you could be a really unattractive
woman but you still want a guy that's a
CEO so what's happened is people are not
accepting their true level and that
becomes a very difficult playground for
people who are not objectively
attractive talk tell me a little bit
about boundaries in romantic
relationships um and and they are
essential in every relationship not just
romantic relationships and they're
usually an extension so when we grow up
with healthy boundaries with our family
members that then translates into
healthy boundaries with friends which
then leads to a natural progression to
healthy boundaries in relationships I
think a lot of men don't understand this
yeah it's a clear transition yeah so so
what healthy boundaries looks like in
parenting is um of course you can have
strict parents who you know might you
know open your post or they might tell
you what time to come home no matter but
you have an emotion they recognize it
and respect it and you do the same for
them you have their emotions respected
so on and so forth and you respect each
other to some extent you allow each
other to be themselves and you give each
other some fundamental respect and
you're not trying to shut each other out
of your lives you're just simply
teaching your children how to behave and
they're teaching you what they want out
of parenting what that looks like in
friendships is you only attach to
friends who align with you who respect
you who treat you well what that looks
like in relationships is you only do
nice things for people who respect you
so you only have sex with men that
respect you or you only invest
financially in women that are loyal to
you there is a tradeoff in psychological
trade-off you're good to people who are
naturally good to you now when that's
broken in any way shape or form in
childhood where boundaries were not
respected they were crossed or you
weren't felt love you might have thought
that there is no boundaries or there is
no you know there is no line you you
just earn love then what you looks like
in friendships is you don't know who you
truly are you just wanten trying to grab
onto any relationship you can have and
uh keep it and you might have to
suppress who you truly are just to fit
in and then what that looks like in
relationships is you think that the only
way to maintain this relationship is to
allow this person to do whatever they
want and you have this mentality of
happy wife happy life or you know just
giving in and you think that by
completely um suppressing your
boundaries will maintain the
relationship but human beings are
looking for boundaries your wife that
tells you I want this that and the other
is still looking for the no she's
looking for where your boundar starts
because we want to know that we're in a
safe space somebody without boundaries
is dangerous to us so what when when we
lack boundaries our relationship is a
it's a slow divorce it's going to get
divorced at some point you're just
delaying it the delay
divorce I I always thought it was crazy
we're teaching so many things in in
school and high school history and
trigonometry and geometry but
interacting with other human beings is
never really taught I I used to be a
psych ology teacher for many years and I
couldn't believe that this isn't
compulsory when I was teaching the
children about the effects of a childood
in particular and particular the effects
of trauma in ch in children and how that
affects your development how that
affects your education I couldn't
believe this is not compulsory why are
we not teaching people that if you treat
children like this they go on to be
difficult teenagers and then they go on
to be difficult partners and then they
go on to be difficult parents wouldn't
we be doing such a service if we just
teach people this but this is where the
Advent of the internet is great because
you can access this information but then
you can also access the wrong advice and
the wrong advice is usually far more um
easy to watch so it can go either or is
there is there a lot of misinformation
plenty particularly for men there is so
much misinformation for men it's um
teaching them that you just have to be
really rich and successful and every
woman will submit to you you attract the
worst women when you're really rich and
successful or it's teaching them treat
mean keep them Keen if you just you know
play hard to get and you treat her badly
she'll run after you I'm not disagreeing
with that but it will only be broken
women that attached to that method only
a broken woman would really attach to
inconsistency so if you're going to play
these games treat them mean keep them
Keen or you're going to cheat on them
and then show them that you're the man
and you can be an alpha man with several
women you are filtering out healthy
women who want a monogamous healthy
marriage cuz they can't keep up with
that mentality they also have a very uh
healthy sense of self and self-esteem
they don't allow someone to treat them
me to keep them clean so when you me do
these kind of tricks you are filtering
out healthy women and only inviting
self-sabotaging women into your
world once you get involved with someone
who's who comes from a broken childhood
or
from uh where they had childhood abuse
whatever of whatever sort is there ever
any hope of them functioning normally in
a
relationship you know I don't want to be
negative in any way shape or form but
what I would say is if there's one
broken person in a relationship but
there's two one has a broken perhaps
circumstances and the other one attaches
to people with broken circumstances
because they believe that if they show
them a different route now this person
will forever be in love with me but
which rarely works out it rarely works
out and if it does work out the person
is no longer attracted yeah what the
moment look we're attracted to what we
our our childhood shapes what we know
love to be if you are completely
opposite to the alcoholic father that we
had or the neglecting mother and you're
the exact opposite of that we might
appreciate you for a minute but that
doesn't feel like love because love felt
like this at home so you are just going
to either we're going to push you until
you become like that aggressive parent
or we'll replace you with somebody who
feels like home some people like broken
Birds yeah that's what they how they
designed unfortunately and I I don't
mean this negatively because I don't
want anyone to just you know oh if they
are watching this and they come from a
broken home or they come from a broken
background think they it's Doom and
Gloom but until you acknowledge and
resolve this you will
literally the trauma is contagious and
you traumatize the person that's trying
to love you but the problem can be that
that's the only type of person that
you're sexually attracted to but then
you have to ask yourself why why are you
attracted to Brokenness either you don't
feel worthy of somebody whole and you
feel like if I meet somebody with high
self-esteem
she will realize that I have low
self-esteem and therefore we're not
compatible or there might have been a
Brokenness that you you might have had a
parent that was overdependence on you
and you had to kind of heal and soothe a
very broken mother and you think that
that's how you became a good boy and
this is what Mak makes creates love when
really in the real world it doesn't
create love because here's the thing
when we are super super broken as a
woman or as a man when we are truly
broken the person that's trying to love
us is somebody we can't understand if I
know I've got all these demons and you
are giving me love consistency honesty
transparency I don't think wow thank you
I just think what's wrong with you why
would you want to love someone like me
there must be something wrong in you so
I will literally try and find the flaw
in you until you
leave lot of people push people away
they push people away so if you find
yourself attracted to Brokenness you
have to ask yourself are you truly what
is it about the the Brokenness that
you're trying to heal what what are you
getting from it and is it are you truly
attracted to the Brokenness or are you
just making the the fact that they're
your physical type the priority and then
glossing over the traumas just dealing
with all the other dealing with it
because that's usually what I find I'll
find these helpers um but they usually
are they're only this way because they
just say this is what one of the lines
men will say when I see a broken woman I
just want to help her I'm just such a
empathetic person I just want to help
her and I said do you do that if she's
fat and
and you'll say yes on the street maybe I
might help and I like you do not do that
to fat ugly broken women you do it to
beautiful women and the moment she's
beautiful you don't mind if whatever
trauma she has you want to be save the
day Dave but is that was truly your
character you would it would transcend
appearance so truly you might be just
putting looks on a pedestal as well is
it ever a fear of commitment so I think
so you're choosing a person who's
impossible to really get connected with
yeah that's a great question question
sorry to interrupt you in the middle of
it but that's a great question because
sometimes we choose broken or somebody
with holes in it because then we can
predict the break we can predict when
it's going to end somebody perfect would
mean that maybe we'll end up together
forever and I don't really want that but
somebody with lots of holes in them I
know at some point it's going to run its
course and then I can won't hurt so bad
because I can say well I always knew she
was like this or I always knew he was
like this so it's not that painful so
it's it's definitely a fear of
commitment as well you see so often
women are attracted to bad boys and you
see men that are attracted to crazy
girls that are particularly attractive
are the particularly attractive
females kind
of working on their attractiveness
because they know that's the only tool
they've got uh yeah when women are
vacuous broken yeah when they're vacuous
what they learn is some men don't
require you to have anything else so
then they use every man that they're
with to get a new cosmetic surgery so
what they'll do is they'll be with one
guy and say can you pay for my my boobs
another guy can you pay for my lips can
can you pay for my CU they learn very
quickly that for a lot of these low
self-esteem men that's all they actually
care about and so the aging process is
something that they constantly fight
against but I would say in general
toxicity the reason why we're attracted
to toxicity is when when something is
calm and smooth we don't get preoccupied
with it if I know that you know
something's in the oven it's on low heat
I'm not going to worry about it but when
something's boiling on the cooker and
it's on really high heat I'm like
constantly thinking I'm comly running
back to it so what happens in
relationships the more inconsistent and
the more traumatic the relationship is
the more you get into a limerance stage
of just focusing on it and being
obsessed with it and we mislabel that
Obsession as I must be in love with this
person I must be madly in love with them
I can't stop thinking about them they
all I'm wored but ask yourself are you
thinking about them out of positive
thoughts are usually thinking because
you're worried they're going to hurt you
in certain ways and usually it's the the
latter so I would the relationship is
much hotter more exciting when there's
danger of getting hurt exactly yeah it's
just slightly more danger to it so we
get obsessed with it and the person that
doesn't Pro provide any danger we kind
of forget about so unfortunately we
mislabel that Obsession as chemistry
because that's what we see in the movies
so much what we see in movies and
Cinemas and stuff if you're not
preoccupied with somebody if you're not
thinking about them all the time and if
they're not taking over your brain you
don't care about them and really that is
a signal of Chaos and not somebody you
should be attaching to what what is the
attraction to bad boys
or kind of emotionally unavailable women
that are just crazy uh when you're
younger I think for the bad boy why it's
attractive is here's here's the key with
the bad boy it's only flattering if a
man loves you and is invested in you if
he has Alternatives bad boy tends to
have Alternatives it is not flattering
and a man that has zero Alternatives has
nothing else going on in his life tells
you love loves you so I wouldn't say
we're attracted to Bad Boys we're
probably more attracted to the man that
has a life that he enjoys with or
without us and because he has that you
know whether we call him on the weekend
or not it doesn't matter it either be
somebody else or he's got other things
to go on and do and preoccupy that's the
guy we're slightly more attracted to
whereas the guy that has nothing else
going for him other than his obsession
with ours we don't feel flattered by it
so we we're quite I would say it's more
of a case of we're attracted to men that
have um a life that's worth living with
or without us whereas a man that is just
dedicates everything to us and men think
that they're being really nice and
really devoted it signals um lack of
utility he's not doing enough is is part
of the problem today that we just have
so many choices yeah unfortunately our
parents
generation I know my parents generation
that you found somebody that that you
were attracted to and you just settled
down and that was it they weren't a
thousand other choices that were
possible and we also had limited
understanding of what attractiveness
meant or look like it was just like the
people in your neighborhood or the
people in your area and so now we can
see people all over the world and
they're somewhat accessible there're
somewhat you know you can just like a
few pictures of them and it's so it's
just so different and also the
pornography doesn't help um one of the
things I noticed with men who watch
plenty of porn is they start to have a
particular type but they have nothing in
common with and that leads to a
breakdown in relationship as well what I
mean by this is I'll meet a man who is
living I don't know maybe in New Jersey
and he really really wants to be with a
woman from Thailand and he's obsessed I
like Oriental I just want an oriental
girl so he'll want to go be with that
girl and they have no emotional intimacy
they have nothing in common with each
other they didn't grow up in a similar
World they have no shared norms and
values but he has an obsession and I
always ask ask what is your porn search
and I say oh that's not relevant I've
always liked this I was like it's not
possible I was like it's not possible
because genuinely what's happening is
you're um bypassing emotional and
intellectual intimacy and making this
your criteria the relationship is not
going to have enough to sustain it I'm
not saying you can't have crosscultural
relationships but without emotional and
intellectual intimacy they will fall
apart and that's why a lot of you know
in America there's a lot of this
passport browers guys that will go
abroad and find they don't last because
there's not enough of that um connection
and one thing with women they would
always look for connection so let's say
for example she is from Thailand and she
marries this guy from the US and all
this stuff she will still keep in touch
with the guy that she went to school
with who's probably sending nuts on the
street she'd still want to be with him
because he understands her in a way that
no one else can so we look for
familiarity but men look to familiarity
in terms of what they're sexually
attracted to we look for familiarity and
what we're emotionally attracted
to you I think you and I are in
agreement about the how how Terri how
destructive pornography is for for
especially for men in our
society it seems like that that's a can
that can't be shut it's it's it's going
to be hard to close that yeah hard to
get rid of it now I'm definitely not
going to change the world with um
pornography is something that I when I
first started social media um somebody
asked me in an interview what would you
like to take like achieve from this and
I said I would like to wake people up to
pornography if I can if I can take away
anything from this experience of being
on social media is to wake people up to
the dangers of pornography and one of
the reasons why I when I whenever I
speak to a man who's highly manipulated
by women and been cheated on several
several times by a woman I always ask
them do you watch a lot of porn and they
say why is that relevant they'll call me
and saying I caught her sleeping with
her ex and this that other like for
example I had a client who is a
billionaire right and he um is 43 years
old and you know he just got cheated on
by a young girl very young girl young
beautiful girl and um you know she was
living a whole separate life behind his
back and the first question I said to
him is are you watching pornography and
he couldn't understand why I asked him
that and he said why are you asking me
that and he and I said because if you're
45 years old and this girl is 20 years
old and you are sexually
compatible that means that she is very
promiscuous but because you're so used
to pornography you don't see that as a
red flag you see it as great I've met a
girl that lets me do what I want to her
she lets me choke her out she lets me
throw cucumbers in her wherever I don't
know what they do in p i don't watch it
but I he he kept talking about how much
they had physical chemistry and I said
but didn't you see it as a red flag that
if you're 20 years older than a girl and
she can keep up with you sexually don't
you see that as a red flag that she must
have had had a lot of history and she
has a promiscuous nature and he said I
never thought about it that way and I
said because you're watching pornography
when you're watching pornography what
happens is extreme sexual behavior
instead of seeing it as extreme you see
it as exciting desirable this is exactly
what I'm looking for so you take that
lens into the dating scene so when you
meet women who are healthy they don't
allow extremities they just don't let
you or it takes a really long time for
them to let you touch them like that or
they have to establish a lot of love and
connection first but when you meet a
hyper promiscuous woman who might have a
really extensive sexual past she'll
allow you to do that on the first night
and when you're not watching pornography
you'll think how did this young girl
just let me do that to her on the first
night how come she so up for three SS
and like I've only known her a couple of
weeks but when you are watching
pornography you're thinking dream girl
you're thinking this is my dream girl
I'm going to marry this girl I can't
believe how great she is so the main
main thing what it does is it takes a
man's natural disgust that he should
have towards priscu I'm not saying this
in a misogynous way it's just as a male
protective strategy you should have a
natural St towards priscu because then
you don't know who the father of the
child is and evolved in a way that you
shouldn't be too attracted it takes
their natural disgust and rep with
promiscuity and replaces it with intense
desire and love so you take what should
be a red flag and you replace it with
Obsession and that's it's all down to
pornography s what would you say is the
most important thing people should keep
in mind with romantic relationships um
pick somebody's whose past like
childhood is compatible with yours yeah
pick I I'm from a Muslim background my
parents are Pakistani and you know in
our culture we have arranged marriages I
didn't have arranged marriage but we
have arranged marriages growing up I
thought it so bizarre like where are
they getting this idea how does that
make any sense blah blah um doing the
work I've done I how I know a couple's
going to last when I go to their wedding
is I can't tell whose family is whose
because they're so similar to each other
I remember going to a friend of mine's
wedding and I was like oh is that
Steve's family or is it your family
she's like it's my family and I was like
oh they you know they're so similar and
they're so in sync with each other I
didn't know whose was whose now when I
go to other weddings where I see one has
a completely different set of values to
the other
though I got a feeling it's not going to
last so long and I don't mean like in
terms of race or anything I just mean in
terms of value system when you could
tell two values are so so opposite one
is you know really conservative and
comes from a really a lot of stability
and the other one comes through a lot of
chaos and there's a lot going on and
it's completely different unfortunately
when push comes to shove what keeps us
together is our shared norms and values
if we don't have them we won't have
them excellent Sadia Khan thank you so
much no thank you so much fascinating
insights into what we all go through
thank you relationships thank you so
much thank you for having me all
right